Hello nice to meet you both and
congratulations thank you thank you how
are you I am doing very well I'm sitting
home sweet home with a cat in my lap
talking about a good movie so it's okay
right now uh Daisy I'll come your way
first on this so you've obviously had
some experience adapting very popular
books to screen before so is there any
big takeaway from your experience
working on normal people that you found
influencing your approach to how you
brought Kaya to screen here I think the
main thing being knowing that it's not
it's never going to be exactly how you
want to imagined it you know it's always
going to be different to the book and
accepting that and enjoying that
difference and allowing yourself to sort
of create another angle into a character
um for an audience and yeah I think I I
think you know I kind of went did the
same thing of of lifting passages from
the book that I loved and putting it by
my script which I did for Marianne as
well and getting the accent right and
things like that but um but yeah I think
it was enjoying stepping into a
filmmaker's version of of the story and
and enjoying the collaborative aspect of
it okay so speaking of that a question
for both of you now so you've got the
source material you also have Lucy
script but is there any additional
character work you both can do on your
own that you know maybe we don't
necessarily hear or see on screen but we
can feel influencing your performance in
these roles
um I said this earlier but I definitely
had um a playlist that I created for
Tate and so I would you know listen on
the way to sat on the way home
um you know and days I had off and I
just kind of sit with those songs
um that made me feel like I was uh
something something that a soundtrack
they would carry along with him you know
wherever he went can you share some of
those songs uh lots of Al Green
um
yeah
okay I'll take it yeah
um I did the same I had a playlist too
and and and then I also sort of um there
was other skills that we learned like
boat riding and and um and uh fishing
and I did a little bit of drawing and
things like that but really just reading
and rereading and rereading and
re-reading the book uh you know um which
feels like an obvious one but it feels
like the more you read it it will kind
of start to like get under your skin and
and things like that so yeah all right
Taylor for you specifically now I feel
like I've seen you in a whole lot of
action thrillers lately minus I guess
maybe sharp objects which is coming to
mind now but given the fact that this is
much more drama and romance leaning is
there any particular I don't know I
guess a new skill that you could add to
your uh tool kit of acting skills that
specifically came from jumping into this
genre with this type of story
um I don't know I've always picked like
uh you know character driven projects
sometimes they're action thrillers and
sometimes they're you know romance
mystery murder who done it
um but uh yeah it's kind of always the
same I'm always trying to pick new
things from each project and and grow
with them and and learn new skills so
it's just a process just a process of
growing with each project The Outpost is
quite good but I will forever have
Shadow in the clouds
that is something else thank you uh for
both of you now I always love
highlighting the value of a good scene
partner so to make each other blush a
little bit can each of you tell me
something that the other did for you on
this set that you really appreciated
maybe something that helped you bring
something out of your own character that
you wouldn't have been able to reach
without them well I agree with you
completely I always think you're only as
good as the the actor in the scene with
you and I feel like with with this I
felt so lucky every day going to play
those scenes with Taylor because he has
such a sort of deepness to him and and a
Nuance in his performance that he
brought to Tate which really allowed me
to kind of find a different avenue into
that relationship than I had sort of
initially kind of thought about and I
think you know especially because there
was times where we had to be really
vulnerable knowing that the person
behind the camera is really kind and
giving you so much off camera too you
know and feeding your performance it
just yeah ultimately my performance is
only down to what he was giving me the
other side of the camera so yeah that is
the sweetest thing
oh my God
just you hear like absolute kindness and
I was really impressed by your your
dedication
um obviously she's had to learn so many
different things for this film
um and she's insanely talented but I've
never seen work ethic like this before I
mean for the you know month and a half
leading up to our starting of filming
she's doing you know dialogue lessons
um she was going on nature walks getting
comfortable with her feet being
absolutely destroyed because she's not
wearing shoes
um doing the movement coaches and
learning how to ride boats and fish and
just be in that world and then getting
to see her on the first day of set I'm
like oh my God this is this is why she
is as good as she is because of all the
hard work she puts in I was very
impressed by you
face here I was reading that uh you have
a knack for learning new accents is
there any particular one that you know
could be the most challenging for you
down the line one you find most
intimidating I think I find I'd find
like for some reason Welsh or like a
Geordie accent
um hard
um yeah so maybe because because in the
UK we have such like you know such a
kind of range of accents you can walk 20
minutes up the road and have an entirely
different dialect and and yeah so I
would find maybe maybe Welsh quite
difficult because it's very sing-songy
and I yeah I don't I can't tune my ear
to it quite yet I'll I'll get it I just
need to practice I believe in you I have
full faith
um so of course you have a plus scene
Partners all around in this movie but
there are a pretty significant amount of
uh highly emotional beats that are just
you by yourself so how does your
approach to tackling one of those scenes
differ compared to when you have a scene
partner to do it with I think that you
know I what I love about filmmaking is
that it really is a collaboration and so
much of a performance is also uh created
for you by a choice of camera and music
and edit and I think with those dialogue
free scenes you know so much of the
story is being told for you by the
choice of camera and I I find that very
interesting I love staying on set and
hearing the discussion about why they've
decided to place the camera above you
because it makes you seem small and
vulnerable or why it's below because it
makes you seem powerful and I think
allowing yeah just enjoying the fact
that you know it is a team effort to
tell and a story and viewer scene with
meaning I find very fun so yeah okay so
bringing up the team effort I'm tempted
to ask this now I know every single
person who worked on this film is
incredible but I always love asking for
an unsung hero so we know you we know
Olivia is there anybody who worked on
where the crawdad's saying that doesn't
necessarily get the attention that they
deserve that you know you would shout
out right now someone who made an
especially difficult day on set easier
for you
oh that's hard there's so many unsung
heroes really craft services for sure
um providing that watermelon when you
need it exactly
um Francie Brown was was awesome
um she was our dialect coach and I don't
think I could have gone close to any of
it without her so grateful for that yeah
and I think mirror not our customer too
she was always so like cheerful and fun
and
um you know because it can be so
difficult she was always just so lovely
and and to see the world that she
created through her costumes and the
story she was telling was really was
really amazing so yeah all right I can't
tease a cat at the beginning and not do
the video
very happy to be here I swear oh that is
a lovely oh wow I'm so mad that I just
woke him he's the man
that's it that's a wrap uh I was
probably very happy right now
congratulations and have a good time
celebrating the release thank you so
much